[Music]
my girlfriend
uh recently had a miscarriage and it was
doubly bad because i
had to pay for it
hey the truth my wife and i we never
have something now we can undress we
can't stop laughing
but i'll tell you what if my wife does
have sex she screams oh especially when
i walk in on her
and also you got to die to go to hell
and i don't want to die i like my life
i'm very happy i'm married and i love my
wife i love her very much
my wife hates me she [ __ ] hates me
she hates me so much
like that's what she does like if you
ask her what'd you do today i [ __ ]
hate that guy that's what i did today
i hate louie
she's so mad at me all the time here's
the latest thing the other day she got
really mad she said to me you know what
you did
you filled the dishwasher with dishes
you put this open and you didn't turn it
on
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
what are we gonna do now
but here's the part where she blows my
mind this is amazing when she gets to
this level she says well
why didn't you turn it on
like i have a reason for not turning it
on
and i'm like can't i just be stupid
can't it just be that i'm a [ __ ]
idiot that i filled the dishwasher and
then i went
boom i walked away
i can live with that i'm cool with that
but she says no
why'd you do it which means i decided
not to do it do you know how much more
of an [ __ ] that makes me
that means i filled the dishwasher then
i went you know what [ __ ] her i ain't
turning it on
she can suck my dick if she thinks i'm
pressing that on button
i'll fill it but i don't [ __ ] press
on not in my own house
why would i do that that would be crazy
the thing that she's usually mad about
is simple she says that i don't listen
to her
when she's talking and i don't
but it's not because i don't love her
blah blah it's because
i try to listen i really do when she
talks i just stare at her face i'm like
come on
bring the story
but somehow i'm like what the [ __ ] i
can't do it i try
because every story gets divided into 50
stories that all branch out
into these crazy and i'm like holy [ __ ]
i've got add i can't do it i'm like
[ __ ] please
[Applause]
but i try every time i try because i
love this [ __ ] woman so i try really
hard
to listen to her stories
other people don't even try we go to
parties she starts talking people just
walk away like [ __ ] this that lady's
crazy
who would waste time listening to that
crap me
[Applause]
she can't help it i really feel bad for
because the thing is that every word of
the story gets her so excited that she
wants to [ __ ] run with it and
she can't [ __ ] just break through and
get to the end or even the beginning
this is my wife telling a story she's
like guess what happened to my mom today
i was done you remember i told you my
mom how she when she was in college not
when she went to michigan when she
transferred
remember because that guy got weird and
she had to leave because he was not the
iranian guy that was a different story
that guy actually i think he was persian
i heard that persia actually split what
the [ __ ] are you talking about
[Applause]
jesus christ
pick a thing have some consideration for
the [ __ ] listener
i don't do that here's me telling a
story i bought a tomato and i ate it and
it was good
that's a story anyone can follow it's
about a tomato the whole time
i like being married though i do i
really like it i seriously do we're
having sex with my wife and i a couple
weeks ago
which is amazing that we did that
because
we never have sex never because we have
a baby and our baby's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
won't let us have sex
oh [ __ ] that kid's a jerk man seriously
every time she's got some urgent [ __ ] in
her room papa come in here
i meant now okay i go in there what's up
i need a pair of pants to put on my pony
wow holy [ __ ]
i'm trying to [ __ ] your mom in there
would you give me a break
can a guy [ __ ] your mom for a minute
[Applause]
i go into an argument with my girlfriend
she said you treat this house like a
hotel
i said i have never snorted cocaine off
the hook as tits in this house
i got married three years ago and i'm
not lonely too much now anymore and i
got a good woman to say it i got a woman
who loves me for my money and my fame
and not for what i am
i'm leaving a comedy club in san jose
california
and i'm walking back to my hotel room
which is one block away
as i'm walking i pass in front of this
bar on the corner called
cnet bar it's got all kinds of cinema
and movie memorabilia in there it looks
cool
i'm walking in front and there are
people in that bar that just left my
show so i walk in front and i heard
fluffy hey let me buy you a shot
i was like well you know i don't want to
be rude
can't have that right so i walked in i
said what's it you know i'm on my way
back to my room i just do a couple shots
whatever so you know one shot and then
somebody me two all right me too
let's do it me three me four
15 shots of tequila later
it occurs to me i think i should go
i start walking towards the door i took
three steps the cold air hit me
i got dizzy and i fell hard i know i
fell hard cause when i hit the ground i
i got farted my buddy martine ran over
and he helped me up off the ground
are you okay here okay we stumbled back
to the hotel room i sit down in the
lobby and i'm just like
are you okay gabriel i'm okay man
where's my phone i gotta let my girl
know i'm okay
you're holding it oh thank you martine i
love you i love you your girlfriend man
you're a girlfriend
because what are you doing i'm a text
dude just call her no
if i call her she's gonna know
something's up i'ma text her watch
baby i made it back to the hotel
i love you
sand clean how
did it go i farted
i shouldn't tell her that okay it went
good
what did you do after your show
oh here we go
my buddy martine is like cable man
gabriel don't tell her don't tell you at
a bar getting drunk man
don't tell her martine i have to tell
her the truth bro
we're cool like that man i could talk to
her
i could i could tell her anything man
she's not like your old lady you know
tripping all the time hey martin take
the pictures of the coaching off the
internet
whatever i'm sorry did i say that out
loud forgive me bro
gabriel lie i can't lie man lie i can't
lie
are you that honest no i just won't
remember the lie
i get in trouble two times for the same
stupid thing you know
so i sent the message baby i made it
delete delete delete baby
i went next door with martine
to cena bar
had a nice time kissy face kissy face
kissy face send
clean lucky you wish i could have been
there with you
tell martin i said hi i love you
oh my god martin
i just told my girlfriend i was at a bar
with you and she didn't get mad what the
hell is she doing
[Music]
man she told me to tell you hi and she
don't even like you
so i scroll back to read what she read
and apparently my stupid iphone has this
memory spell check feature
and it didn't recognize the word cnet
bar
it flipped it and turned it into
cinnabon
so apparently at 10 o'clock at night my
girlfriend thought i was having cinnamon
rolls with my friend martine
which normally would sound like an ugly
lie but considering her boyfriend is
known as the fluffy guy who loves
chocolate cake
it sounds real i was like oh my god
martin check it out my iphone lied for
me
blackberry can't do that
i told my girlfriend my ultimate sexual
fantasy was to have two women at the
same time and she agreed
but then she was livid when i told her
she wasn't either of them
she was going to be the one outside
washing the car
i mean the last time i made love to my
wife it was ridiculous
nothing was happening i looked right so
what's the matter can't you think of
anyone either
a girlfriend with too many guy friends
hey old dr bill
i'm a 21 year old college student and i
started dating this girl at my school
five months ago
things seem to be going great but
unfortunately we've been away from each
other this summer because
we're from different states we talk
almost every day
but there are some days when i never
hear from her at all i just see her
posting different things she does with
their friends on social
media i would have a problem with i
wouldn't have a problem with it
except hang on a second what the [ __ ]
broccoli it's just never done
um sorry guys i promise i won't eat
again
on the podcast it's really rude i i know
i know it's horrible sorry
uh we talked about i wouldn't have a
problem with it except the majority of
the time
it's with a group of dudes she's always
hanging out with about five of her
friends who are all guys and then a
handful of times
there's other girls there every time i
see her post something about them i feel
jealous and angry that she's spending
all this time with other guys
not only that but her most recent post
was on a boat with all these guys
wearing prop
wearing probably her most revealing
bikini
i haven't met any of these guys so i
definitely don't trust any of them
and whenever she's with them and i text
her she takes hours to respond
or even waits to the next day i i want
to bring it up
how i feel about that but i don't want
to make it feel like i'm telling her who
she can and can't
hang out with so what do you think i
should do bring it up
um that i don't like how she hangs out
with other guys or just shut the [ __ ] up
and trust that she's not up to anything
uh would be great to hear from nia
thanks
uh what nia thinks to get a female
perspective too i wish she was here
right now because uh
you're gonna get my perspective um
anyway sorry for the long email
hopefully it didn't
i didn't use too many big words for you
yeah go [ __ ] yourself
um what do i think about that
uh yeah that's kind of weird i mean
what would she think if you were [ __ ]
hanging out with like five other broads
and you were wearing a speedo when you
got didn't get back to her the next day
she'd probably think that you were
[ __ ] around right
so i would just i would just say to us
hey listen i'm not trying to be a jerk
here but uh you know when you post
you know when you're hanging out you
seem to only be hanging out with other
guys you're on boats you're wearing
skimpy bikinis it's it's making me feel
uncomfortable here
all right she's like oh yeah you know
and just go look i'm just communicating
that it it kind of makes me
uncomfortable
um
yeah this is real difficult without you
seeming like you're [ __ ] checking in
on her and being like a jerk but just
just ask her just so let me ask you this
if you know if i didn't if i text you
and i didn't get back you text me and i
didn't get back to you for a
whole full [ __ ] 24 hours
all right and then you see a picture on
facebook and i'm standing there with my
ball bag all in a bunch
you know all wadded up like a [ __ ]
packed parachute
hanging out with like five chicks on a
boat
i mean wouldn't you kind of be like you
know dude what the [ __ ]
just ask your am i out of line here
then also tell it too and please tell me
you know if you're not feeling it
anymore and you want to hook up with
other guys
just let me know early on so you know
the heartache
is way less just let me know all right
but i dude i don't think that it's weird
that you're uncomfortable with that that
is [ __ ] weird
um you know hanging out with five guys
in your most revealing [ __ ] bikini
give me a you know what the [ __ ] you
doing
no those are just my guy friends all
right now i'm getting annoyed huh what
are you a [ __ ] attention [ __ ] what's
gonna say all the [ __ ] that you can't
say to him this is all the [ __ ] you're
thinking and you're totally justified to
think of it
and don't listen to any [ __ ] broads
or tell you anything different because
if you were doing it
they give you the exact same [ __ ]
[ __ ] all right i got my footing on this
one
all right just ask her just ask her what
is what's you know
don't stew in the tone then i'm doing it
you got to ask what the [ __ ] going on
here
you know honey with all due respect
i mean you [ __ ] it looks like you
you're in a sausage factory there
you know wearing your little skimpy
[ __ ] outfit what's going on
be one thing if you were there with one
of your girlfriends and even then i'm
thinking a little five on two action
right
what's going on i don't know what to
tell you dude
that's that's a [ __ ] up situation uh
it might be just
how she like she may be always good i
don't like other girls i don't get along
with other girls she may be one of those
[ __ ] people
well really you like hanging out with
guys why don't you do it with some
[ __ ] clothes on how about that you
know
how about this can we can we make a rule
that uh you know you gotta put on some
[ __ ] clothes when you hang out with
these guys
how about that because you know you're
just gonna get pissed and then you're
gonna start hanging out with some chicks
and just to piss her off you're gonna
start taking [ __ ] pictures
and not return her [ __ ] text for a
day and you start doing that childish
[ __ ]
rather than just getting right to the
[ __ ] meat of the heart of the matter
there right
the meat of the matter look at this
that's how much instead of saying the
heart i said the meat that's how much
i'm [ __ ] hating these vegetables
oh geez yeah